[Musique]
déterminez le moment du décès quand
survient la découverte d'un corps au
milieu naturel représente souvent tout
un défi à l'Université du Québec à
Trois-Rivières des chercheurs
perfectionnent leurs connaissances pour
mieux estimer ce délai poster
vous êtes en forêt vous découvrirez sans
le vouloir des restes humains un mort
qui est cette personne comment est-elle
morte depuis combien de temps
que la mort soit naturelle accidentelle
ou criminel on doit faire parler le
corps
pour remonter dans le temps les
chercheurs analysent l'état des restes
humains mais la nature du climat peut
tout changer quant au rythme de
décomposition du corps
on a des connaissances très partielles
sur la manière dont les corps
décomposent au cours du temps dans notre
climat local qui est un climat
continental humide on en sait très peu
de choses et on est en train grâce aux
recherches qu'on mène actuellement sur
notre site de bécancourt de pouvoir
contribuer à enrichir les connaissances
sur ce sujet là
derrière cette clôture se cache un
laboratoire à ciel ouvert
sécuriser l'accès il restreint seul ses
chercheurs en sciences judiciaires
accèdent aux corps des donneurs qui
reposent sur le site
[Musique]
c'est le seul et unique laboratoire du
genre au Canada les autres sont situés
aux États-Unis en Australie et aux
Pays-Bas
celui-ci était installé en plein or en
pleine forêt dans un lieu semblable à
celui dans lequel on pourrait retrouver
des corps
au Canada et au Québec en particulier
cette forêt d'érable est représentative
de la forêt boréale c'est ce qu'on
souhaitait recréer en choisissant ce
site
trouve en ce moment déposé sur le sol à
l'air libre ils sont couverts d'une cage
grillagée elle empêche les bêtes
sauvages de les atteindre tout en
permettant aux insectes du circuits tous
les donneurs ont volontairement choisi
de participer à ce projet de recherche
à l'extérieur de cette enclos décadambre
de cochons sont disposés de la même
façon
ce sont ces ossements de cochons qu'on
voit manipuler par les chercheurs
leur examen sur le site est un
laboratoire permet de suivre la
dégradation d'un cadavre animal et
humain en parallèle parce que les
cochons bien qu'ils aient des points
communs avec nous ils ont aussi un
certain nombre de différences et c'est
ces différences là notamment la quantité
de gras ce qu'on appelle les tissus
adipeux font une différence dans la
manière dont le corps d'un cochon va
décomposer par rapport un cadavre humain
utilisez des restes humains améliore la
fiabilité de nos données quand vient le
temps d'estimer le moment de la mort
d'une personne et les circonstances
entourant sont décès
c'est le genre d'information qu'on peut
être appelé à fournir à la cour comme
témoin expert durant les enquêtes
criminelles
les premiers corps ont été déposés sur
le site en 2020 depuis les chercheurs en
sciences médicaux légales attente le
lieu ils sont chimiste microbiologistes
entomologistes ou entrepreneurs
judiciaire ils observent de près la
transformation des corps depuis le décès
on part du connu pour dans le futur
lorsque des restes humains non
identifiés sont trouvés en contexte
forrentique réel on va pouvoir appliquer
ses connaissances là développer dans un
contexte connu un contexte inconnu
[Musique]
les insectes sont parmi les premiers
acteurs de la décomposition
Julie Éléonore Maison Haute les études
elle se réfère parfois la collection
automobile où elle est Robert pour un
identifier certains
nombreux et variés les insectes
débarquent à tour de rôle en fonction du
stade des compositions et de la
température alors les insectes peuvent
nous aider à déterminer un intervalle
post mortem donc c'est à dire
le moment du décès en fait et
connaissant l'espèce qui était présente
sur le cadavre et les données de
température aussi on peut retrouver le
moment à partir duquel les premières
mouches ont pondu sur sur le corps
en laboratoire à Trois-Rivières on
procède aussi à l'élevage des larves
d'insectes récoltés plus tôt sur le
corps des donneurs
faute de pouvoir les identifier à ce
stade c'est dans ces pots qu'elle
complète leur développement
elles seront nourries et maintenues dans
un environnement contrôlé
[Musique]
on va essayer de venir reproduire les
conditions environnementales normales
selon la saison donc moi vu que c'était
une étude qui faisait durant l'été je
vais essayer d'avoir une photo période
qui ressemble beaucoup à ce qu'on
retrouve durant l'été donc environ le 14
heures de luminosité puis un petit 10
heures de nuit de noirceur
une fois la larve devenue adulte on peut
identifier l'espèce
en début de décomposition quand les
insectes sont plus actifs l'estimation
du délai postmortem peut être de l'ordre
de plus ou moins un jour
[Musique]
plus le temps avance moins précis
mais les insectes peuvent aussi indiquer
qu'un corps a été déplacé par exemple on
retrouve un corps en pleine forêt comme
ça peut être assez fréquent et qu'on
retrouve sur ce corps là une espèce de
mouche mais qui est plutôt associée au
milieu urbain et qu'on retrouve très peu
en milieu forestier
on peut se poser des questions et
soupçonner que le corps a été déplacé
donc la personne a été tuée plus en
milieu urbain et a été déplacé par la
suite en milieu forestier
[Musique]
en hiver bien entendu les insectes
s'éclips mais on a découvert que la
décomposition des cornes ne s'arrête pas
pour autant
la neige on sait maintenant qu'à cause
de la neige qui agit comme un isolant la
température près du corps demeure autour
de 0°c
et la prolifération des bactéries la
décomposition se poursuit donc mais à un
rythme plus lent
dans ces circonstances on pourrait sûr
ou sous-évaluer le moment de la mort à
la vue de l'état des restes humains
plus tard avec l'arrivée du printemps
puis de l'été la chaleur va de nouveau
accélérer la décomposition des corps et
la libération de gaz et de composés
organiques
l'objet de mes travaux de recherche
consiste à voir comment ces produits se
dégradent et lesquels peut-on identifier
dans l'environnement que ce soit dans
l'air comme les odeurs ou dans le sol
sous un corps même après qu'il ait été
déplacé
pour emprisonner ces gaz émis par les
corps on dépose pendant quelques minutes
un caisson métallique par-dessus le
donneur une ouverture au sommet permet
de capturer les gaz qui s'y accumulent
les composés organiques donc ce pique là
pourrait représenter un alcool celui-là
pourrait représenter un Esther
avec le temps les cadavres de cochons
comme ceci laissent des traces dans
l'environnement mais l'environnement
laisse aussi des traces sur les restes
qu'ils soient humains ou animaux
et tu vois cette tâche de verre
elle est issue de lichen
et ou de champignons et cette marque
elle est précieuse pour nous en propose
parce que elle nous révèle des
informations ça veut dire que le corps
était dans un environnement ouvert en
extérieur donc la personne est décédée
et que son corps a décomposé au moins
partiellement en nature autre exemple à
l'automne quand les feuilles tombent et
se décomposent le niveau d'acidité du
sol change cela va interférer dans le
processus de décomposition des corps
plus tard en hiver le froid le vin et le
temps sec auront un effet inattendu sur
les corps les desséchés
on a découvert que le corps pouvait
rapidement perdre l'eau qu'il contient
ce qui stoppe le travail des bactéries
et la décomposition
la peau prend un aspect de cuir c'est ce
qu'on appelle la momification cela
préserve le corps
certains tissus peuvent se figer en
quelque sorte dans le temps les
empreintes digitales ou des traces d'ADN
dans les tissus peuvent être préservés
ce qui peut faciliter l'identification
d'une personne disparue
notre défi est de savoir si ce corps
préservait de la décomposition l'aide
depuis un an ou 10 ans puisqu'il
conserve la même apparence ce combat
entre décomposition et conservation on
ne l'aurait jamais imaginé sans ses
études
le site de bécancourt comment s'appelle
à arriver les skis cache derrière la
décomposition d'un corps sous nos
latitude les donneurs n'auraient sans
doute jamais imaginé à quel point leur
don serait utile
on est conscient que
sans eux on pourrait pas effectuer nos
recherches
c'est comme si la mort des uns
permettait de mieux comprendre ou
d'interpréter celle des autres les
disparus
que leurs proches retrouvent parfois des
années plus tard
pour ces proches là tant qu'ils n'ont
pas d'éléments de réponse sur les
circonstances du décès de leurs proches
ils sont incapables de faire leur deuil
et moi j'ai à cœur d'essayer dans la
mesure du possible d'essayer de
contribuer à pouvoir apporter des
réponses à ceux qui les attendent